[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver sur les chaînes parlementaires
pour un nouveau numéro de Parlement
Hebdo à l'émission qui revient chaque
semaine sur l'actualité du Parlement
avec vos casiers guilders cette semaine
dans la place Raphaël chez l'Ender j'ai
député les républicains bonjour et vous
êtes notamment président de la
commission d'enquête parlementaire qui
va faire la lumière sur la perte de
souveraineté et d'indépendance
énergétique de la France on va en parler
et elle a une cette semaine le
gouvernement qui multiplie le recours au
49-3 à l'Assemblée nationale pour passer
en force ces textes budgétaires les
insoumis et le rassemblement national
dépose de nouvelles motions de censure
pour faire tomber le gouvernement
au Sénat la majorité de droite adopte la
réforme de l'assurance chômage mais
durcit le texte notamment à propos des
demandeurs d'emploi qui refusent des
offres en CDI
et puis coup d'envoi des travaux de la
commission d'enquête de l'Assemblée
nationale sur le nucléaire les députés
les républicains veulent auditionner
Nicolas Sarkozy et François Hollande
[Musique]
Assemblée nationale l'automne budgétaire
est un peu particulier Elizabeth borne a
engagé plusieurs fois la responsabilité
de son gouvernement résultat des courses
et bien l'émotion de censure succèdent
au 49-3 perturbant un peu le calendrier
parlementaire récit d'Elsa mondingaba
c'est une chorégraphie désormais bien
rodée la première ministre traverse le
périmètre sacré monte à la tribune pour
annoncer le recours à l'article 49-3 de
la Constitution en
culpabilité nous devons donner un budget
à notre pays nous ne pouvons pas prendre
le risque d'un nouveau rejet ou d'un
texte de nouveau dénaturé tous les
groupes d'opposition nous avaient fait
savoir qu'il ne voteraient pas le texte
final aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement qui dit 49-3 dit souvent
motion de censure la plus commentée a
été celle déposée par la nupesse sur le
budget l'utilisation du 49-3 et un aveu
de faiblesse pour un gouvernement qui ne
sait pas travailler avec la pluralité
politique de l'Assemblée c'est un mépris
pour la qualité des débats que nous
avons eu depuis plusieurs jours avec un
coup de théâtre ça va m'entorchestrer
par le rassemblement national parce que
seul l'intérêt national guide ses
paroles et ses actes le groupe que j'ai
l'honneur de présider votre a également
la motion de censure présentée en des
termes acceptables de l'autre côté de
l'hémicycle une manière de rendre la
droite responsable du maintien du
gouvernement les républicains n'ayant
pas voté de motion les gens qui ont
proposé d'émotions de censure eux-mêmes
ne font qu'alimenter un espèce de cirque
dont ils savent qu'il n'aura aucune
conséquence je pense que le pays mérite
mieux je pense que le pays a beaucoup
mieux à faire aujourd'hui que le
spectacle un peu ridicule un peu figeant
et se balle des hypocrites entre le RN
et la nups la droite qui dit ne pas
s'interdire de déposer un jour sa propre
motion de censure
sûr une menace jugée par certains peu
crédible
Raven donc Elisabeth borne utilise le
49-3 pour passer en force les textes
budgétaires insoumis et rassemblement
national vont déposer une nouvelle
motion dont déjà déposé elle sera
discuté une nouvelle motion de censure
vous les députés LR vous n'avez pas voté
pour l'émotion qu'on te déposer vous
allez continuer à ne pas voter pour oui
parce que d'abord je crois que il y a
les 49,3 qui vont qui vont se succéder
jusqu'à la fin de l'année en réalité sur
ce même ensemble budgétaire le la façon
dont on vote le budget en français un
peu complexe on a plusieurs votes sur le
projet de loi de finances plusieurs
votes sur le projet de loi de finance de
sécurité sociale et à partir du moment
où dès le départ on n'a pas de moyens de
l'adopter avec une majorité claire à
l'Assemblée nationale on va recourir
pour chacun des votes un peu important
au 49 3 donc d'ici à la fin de l'année
finalement c'est le même on a voté une
fois le sur le 49-3 au début ça va être
la même chose qui va se reproduire
jusqu'à la fin peut-être même en
deuxième lecture mais vous n'avez pas
voté l'émotion déposée par nous n'avons
pas voté ces émotions parce que d'abord
nous avons dit dès le départ que nous ne
voterions pas le budget je crois que ça
c'était la donne de départ ce qui
nécessairement conduisait le
gouvernement à devoir faire adopter son
budget avec le 49-3 puisque il ne
dispose pas d'une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale on comprend pas très bien
votre position pour autant pour autant
je crois que je compte le budgetez pas
pour autant mais pour autant il faut que
il faut que quels sont les solutions
qu'on a là voter le 49-3 c'est-à-dire
faire tomber le gouvernement pourquoi
pour avoir une nouvelle composition de
gouvernement qui représentera le même
budget on a on a posé un certain nombre
de conditions une des conditions par
exemple dans le PLFSS c'était que la
réforme des retraites que nous
considérons importante ne devez pas
figurer dans le projet de loi de finance
ne vais pas devait pas être adopté avec
un mécanisme de type amendement qu'on
aurait glissé par là un peu
subrepticement et bien c'est une
victoire des républicains la réforme la
retraite n'est pas dans le PLFSS nous
aurons une discussion à part donc voilà
donc finalement vous assumez de
maintenir ce gouvernement actuel en ne
participant pas au vote d'émotions de
censure oui parce qu'il y a pas d'autres
solutions aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui d'alternative il n'y a pas
de majorité alternative qui existe à
l'Assemblée nationale et nous n'avons
pas je crois que la France est dans une
situation
on nous avons aussi cette responsabilité
de faire en sorte que ça continue
d'avancer nous ne sommes pas d'accord
sur beaucoup de choses avec le
gouvernement et nous ne cesserons de le
dire pour autant il y a une nécessité
que la France dispose au 1er janvier
d'un budget ça sera pas le nôtre ça sera
celui d'Emmanuel Macron ce sera celui du
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron sur les
réformes au fond par contre il est hors
de question et c'est ce que nous avons
dit toute cette semaine que le
gouvernement procède la même façon avec
les 49-3 le 49-3 budgétaire oui sur les
réformes au fond non alors le patron des
sénateurs LR Bruno Retailleau estime
quand même que les députés à l'air
devront un jour déposer une motion de
censure au du quinquennat vous le ferez
écoutez c'est les termes que je que je
viens de dire
s'il y a une volonté de passer en force
sur des réformes au fond alors nous
prendrons nos responsabilités mais là on
est sur des textes bien particuliers qui
sont les textes budgétaires et la
nécessité de de donner un budget à la
France que Bruno Retailleau dispose
d'une forme de frustration de pas
pouvoir déposer au Sénat une une motion
je le comprends les députés en
responsabilité font leur travail donc si
le gouvernement passe par exemple au
49-3 sur la réforme des retraites les LR
les députés les républicains des
proseront une motion de censure c'est
une hypothèse qui est tout à fait
crédible alors justement puisque les
députés LR ne participent pas au vote
sur ces motion de censure et bien
Emmanuel Macron a estimé cette semaine
qu'il pouvait y avoir une alliance entre
la majorité et les républicains c'est
envisageable non pas l'état actuel
d'abord il y a plusieurs raisons à ça je
crois que aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron a
d'abord beaucoup de problèmes avec sa
propre majorité on voit qu'il est il a
de plus en plus de mal à tenir la guerre
de succession qui est en train de
s'organiser chez Renaissance c'est
d'ailleurs un des problèmes je crois que
le principal problème aujourd'hui il
vient de là on a vu dans la discussion
budgétaire à l'Assemblée nationale le
gouvernement se faire mettre en minorité
par ses propres parties alliés c'est
dire que la situation politique est
complexe qui est manuel Macron s'occupe
déjà de gérer correctement sa majorité
nous savons ce que nous avons à faire
dès le départ nous avons dit que nous
n'étions pas dans une logique d'alliance
de toute façon c'est des choses qui
prennent du temps long je crois
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a pas encore changé
de logiciel qu'il change de logiciel
qu'il montre qu'il est capable d'essayer
de construire du compromis et ensuite
nous pourrons discuter mais c'est
clairement pas le cas aujourd'hui petite
question sur cette motion qui est
déposée motion signée LFI sur le budget
de la Sécurité sociale socialiste et
écologiste ont refusé de la signer
est-ce que vous y voyez un premier signe
d'éclatement de la nupestre c'est qu'on
à l'assemblé international on assiste à
un spectacle politicien assez formidable
c'est ces derniers ces derniers jours
entre Marine Le Pen qui qui précise la
tribune que la nupes ça fait l'effort
d'écrire une motion de censure dans des
conditions acceptables pour qu'elles
puissent la voter enfin c'est un
vraisemblable hein c'est quand même
assez c'est quand même assez choquant et
puis ensuite quand on est dans les
discussions budgétaires où on assiste à
des échanges au sein de la nups on a
parfois l'impression d'être au congrès
fondateur de la nupesse à l'Assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui contre le Parti
socialiste fait valoir sa nuance par
rapport à la France insoumise qui
elle-même est différente des écologies
des Verts qui eux-mêmes se différencient
des communistes enfin c'est c'est assez
passionnant pour tous les observateurs
de la sociologie de la gauche allez
direction le Sénat maintenant puisque le
Sénat a adopté cette semaine la réforme
de l'assurance chômage qui prévoit de
moduler l'indemnisation des demandeurs
d'emploi en fonction de la situation du
marché du travail la majorité de votre
sénatoriales a souhaité durcir ce texte
Sandra
prévu sur trois jours l'examen de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage a été
bouclée en une seule journée le Sénat
majorité de droite a voté en faveur
d'une modulation selon la conjoncture
par décret une baisse possible des
allocations en période d'embellie pour
l'emploi et la possibilité de les
augmenter quand le chômage était élevé
ce mécanisme fait actuellement l'objet
d'une concertation entre le gouvernement
et les partenaires sociaux
ce régime actuel d'assurance chômage
reste pensé construit pour l'essentiel
pour répondre à un concept de chômage de
masse sans être suffisamment incitatif
au retour à l'emploi cela explique
notamment son caractère pour qu'il le
place parmi les plus généreux d'Europe
notamment pour la question de la durée
d'indemnisation ou des seuils
d'éligibilité
les sénateurs à droite ont durci le
texte un amendement vise à exclure de
l'allocation chômage les intérimaires
qui n'acceptent pas un CDI proposé sur
le poste occupé en intérim
autre modification la fin de l'assurance
chômage pour tout demandeur d'emploi qui
refuse trois propositions de CDI suite à
un CDD
un amendement prévoyant la privation
d'indemnisation au premier refus à même
été rejeté d'extrême justesse pour la
rapporteur LR Frédéric puissat c'est une
mesure nécessaire car beaucoup
d'entreprises peinent à recruter dans
certains secteurs les personnes qui
veulent un moment donné avoir des CDD et
les enchaîner sans prendre de CDI bien
entendu que jamais nous nous permettrons
de dire nous refusons ce principe là
simplement nous disons qu'à partir de
moments où on fait ce choix-là on n'a
pas le droit à la location de retour à
l'emploi on ne peut pas faire des choix
de vie chers collègues on ne peut pas
faire des choix de vie qui sont payés
par les systèmes assurantiels voilà
l'objet de cet amendement le Sénat a
voulu montrer son attachement au
paritarisme en redonnant pleinement leur
rôle aux partenaires sociaux pour fixer
les règles d'indemnisation du chômage
ils ont aussi allégé le bonus malus sur
les contrats courts à gauche on dénonce
un texte qui durcit les règles et
stigmatise les demandeurs d'emploi vous
considérez les privés d'emploi comme des
fainéants et des profiteurs
quand même qu'un tiers d'entre elles et
eux ne font pas valoir leurs droits le
chômage est source de souffrance de ma
lettre et entraîne le plus souvent une
perte de confiance en soi ce que vous
refusez obstinément de prendre en compte
député sénateurs vont désormais tenter
de s'accorder sur une version commune du
projet de loi en commission mixte
paritaire le 9 novembre prochain
Raphaël berger ce qui peut y avoir un
accord entre les parlementaires et la
républicains et la majorité pour faire
passer cette réforme de la science
chômage sur ce texte il y aura pas de
difficulté à ce qu'on trouve un accord
d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée nationale de
groupe les républicains avaient voté le
texte en première lecture c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure sur les
réformes de fonds si on travaille au
fond il n'y a pas de difficulté à ce
qu'on arrive à trouver des majorités
lorsqu'elle conviennent à nos
convictions sur ce texte de la réforme
de l'assurance chômage alors évidemment
il y a toujours des choses à faire mais
dans l'ensemble il faut absolument qu'on
avance sur ce sujet là on le voit les
entreprises toutes cherchent à recruter
ont des difficultés et le l'assurance
chômage est devenu pour un certain
nombre de concitoyens un outil de
gestion de carrière c'est pas à la
solidarité nationale de gérer la gestion
de carrière que chacun veuille faire la
carrière qu'il veut les réorientations
de carrière qu'il souhaite oui mais ça
n'est pas à la solidarité nationale de
financer ça alors moduler l'assurance
chômage en fonction de l'état de santé
du marché du travail c'est la c'est ce
que propose cette réforme
en gros plus d'allocations quand ça va
mal moins d'allocations quand ça va bien
vous approuvez cette idée de d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est une bonne idée c'est ce
qu'il faut faire il faut je pense qu'il
faut essayer il va falloir essayer je
peux passer certains que ce soit l'idée
qui marchera le mieux je pense que
parfois des règles claires comprises de
tous sont plus simples mais pourquoi pas
essayer pourquoi pas essayer ce qui est
sûr c'est que les Français ont changé
dans leur rapport au travail ce qui est
sûr c'est que la place de l'emploi
salarié dans notre société a
complètement changé et que notre système
d'assurance chômage lui est resté est
resté là-dessus voilà la société a
changé il faut trouver les moyens
d'adapter éternellement les seniors les
gens qui sont dans des situations
d'intérim et qui ne trouvent pas de sur
l'intérim sur sur l'intérim je crois que
c'est la réalité est un peu plus nuancée
il y a un tas de profession dans
lesquelles on recourt à l'intérim parce
que c'est la seule façon de recruter
pourquoi parce que c'est plus
intéressant de travailler en intérim et
on est loin
euh de l'image d'Épinal qu'on peut avoir
de l'intérim qui est de la chair à canon
social aujourd'hui c'est souvent les
salariés qui décident de de d'être
plutôt dans une logique d'intérim
d'ailleurs on a poussé le bouchon
tellement loin que même dans les
hôpitaux aujourd'hui on va embaucher des
infirmières ou des médecins en intérim
ça déstabilise complètement les services
alors que les structures auraient
largement les moyens d'embaucher est-ce
qu'il faut retenir dans la version
commune de cette réforme les apports de
la majorité de droite du Sénat notamment
en ce qui concerne les personnes qui
refuseraient plusieurs offres en CDI moi
je crois que ce sont des ce sont des
propositions qu'il y a lieu de retenir
de toute façon si Emmanuel Macron qui
semble tendre des mains veut
co-construire avec les républicains mais
il va falloir prendre les propositions
des républicains à l'Assemblée comme au
Sénat donc je crois que ce sont des
propositions de bon sens qui collent à
la réalité économique d'aujourd'hui et
qu'il faut donc reprendre donc justement
un amendement LR à l'Assemblée lors de
la première lecture de ce texte a été
adopté avec l'appui de du gouvernement
c'est à dire que tout tout abandonnée de
poste sera désormais assimilé à une
démission et ne donnera donc pas droit à
des allocations chômage c'est ça que
vous avez négocié pour avec une partie
ça fait partie des marqueurs qui sont
les nôtres et il était important que
qu'on puisse dire à un moment donné le
travail c'est quelque chose de sérieux
encore une fois qu'on veuille changer sa
carrière au fil de de sa vie c'est tout
à fait normale mais il faut le faire en
prenant son risque et pas en demandant à
la société de l'assurer c'est abandon de
poste c'est devenu une façon un peu
sournoise de se faire licencier pour ne
pas avoir à démissionner et bien je
crois que il faut sortir de cette
hypocrisie il y a peut-être un certain
nombre d'effets de bord qui va falloir
corriger aussi parce que parfois dans
certaines situations l'abandon de poste
était la seule ici c'est des choses
qu'il faudra encore corriger je crois
que le gouvernement d'ailleurs dans dans
la façon dont le texte est rédigé qui il
y a quand même beaucoup de liberté
donnée au gouvernement pour agir devra
prendre ces effets de bord en compte
dans sa réforme finalement cette réforme
de l'assurance chômage ça montre qu'il
peut y avoir une alliance de
circonstances entre la majorité et les
républicains mais de circonstances on le
dit depuis le début alors je sais que
certains ne veulent pas l'entendre on
n'est pas dans une logique de pacte de
gouvernement parce que je crois
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'est pas prêt à
entendre tout ce que ça veut dire et ça
veut dire par accepter l'idée qu'il n'a
pas gagné les élections législatives
donc on n'est pas prêt à avoir une
entente globale par contre texte par
texte sujet après sujet nous ferons
valoir nos propositions si les prend en
compte alors nous n'aurons pas de raison
de ne pas les voter d'Emmanuel Macron
qui permettra au gouvernement de faire
passer sur les retraites sur les
retraites aujourd'hui nous sommes très
clairs je crois qu'il faut une réforme
il faut une réforme des retraites notre
système est à bout de souffle ça fait 15
ans qu'on fait des réformes
paramétriques il va peut-être falloir
quelque chose de plus structurel par
contre une réforme ou dès le départ euh
on nous on a un président de la
République qui nous dirait voilà quelle
est la réforme qu'il faut je quand il y
a pas d'espace de discussion je crois
qu'on peut pas trouver d'accord
alors on va parler nucléaire Rafael chez
lamberger puisque vous êtes à la tête de
la commission d'enquête sur la perte de
souveraineté de la France qui a été tout
juste mis en place à l'Assemblée à
l'initiative DLR on en parle mais je
vous propose d'abord d'écouter ce petit
extrait d'audition lucrément prochain
patron d'EDF était entendu parler
députés écoutez ce qu'il dit
je crois qu'il y a pas de stratégie bas
carabone possible sans production
nucléaire
ça a été une conviction française de
longue date ce qui est intéressant c'est
que de plus en plus de pays arrivent à
cette conclusion aujourd'hui constatant
que le nucléaire est la seule
technologie fournissant de l'électricité
de base non carbonée nous avons la
chance que nos anciens aient réussi une
prouesse inouïe qui est développée à la
fois une filière industrielle et de
déployer 58 réacteurs en moins de 20 ans
ce qui nous permet de bénéficier depuis
d'une électricité compétitive et
abondante et des carbonées
voilà alors l'État va arriver à 100% au
capital de EDF et nomme un nouveau
patron quelles sont vos attentes
vis-à-vis de ce groupe qui est en
déroute financières 32 milliards d'euros
de perte cette année à cause de l'arrêt
de la moitié des réacteurs alors les
pertes de DF c'est pas à cause de
l'arrêt des réacteurs c'est un certain
nombre de facteurs qui sont multiples
c'est d'abord la tarif le tarif cette
règle qui oblige EDF à vendre en dessous
de son coût de production de l'énergie
nucléaire assez concurrents qui vont
eux-mêmes revendre l'électricité au prix
du marché c'est à dire beaucoup plus
fort et sans graisser sur le dos d'EDF
qui au passage ne génère du déficit
quand il produit aujourd'hui EDF à cause
de cette règle c'est aussi l'état qui
depuis 10 ans dès qu'il y a une petite
difficulté pour tenir un certain nombre
de choses va piocher dans les caisses
d'EDF qui se comportent plus souvent en
tant qu'actionnaire qui cherche à tirer
un maximum de bénéfices de la part d'EDF
plutôt qu'en état stratège 100% c'est
une nationalisation c'est une prise en
main à 100% du capital EDF reste une
entreprise privée avec 100% de capitaux
publics vous allez me dire c'est une
subtilité qui a un certain nombre de
conséquences quand même là le résultat
il est là et le résultat il est
notamment dans la capacité de DF à
continuer le financement de sa dette je
crois que c'était une nécessité moi je
suis pas favorable tout à fait à cette
voix qui a été prise j'ai vu par exemple
sur mon territoire à quel point ça
pouvait être intéressant que l'État
dispose une forme d'autonomie que DF
dispose d'une forme d'autonomie
vis-à-vis de certains ministres qui
parfois sont tentés de faire n'importe
quoi avec l'énergie donc pour vous c'est
pas forcément une bonne idée alors
Raphaël shelanberger il y a quand même
ce problème des réacteurs à l'arrêt la
moitié du parc à l'entrée de l'hiver
notamment certains réacteurs victimes de
corrosion le patron de l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire là encore rappelé cette
semaine au Sénat c'est parc en mauvais
état c'est la faute à qui à de mauvais
investissements de l'État ou de mauvaise
gestion de déesse ces problèmes de ces
problèmes de sous contrainte qui qui
aujourd'hui mettent une dizaine de
réacteurs à l'arrêt d'ailleurs les
premiers réacteurs qui ont été touchés
par ce problème de corrosion sous
contrainte ont été préparés et sont
remis à disposition du réseau je crois
c'est si vous qui est déjà en production
après avoir été après avoir été repéré
réparé pardon c'est un problème qui est
anticipé de longue date
l'idée d'avoir un problème qui touche
une bonne partie du parc en même temps
c'est quelque chose que DF a anticipé
c'est pour ça que la France a toujours
été en surcapacité de production
seulement ces 10 dernières années on a
fermé plus de 15 gigawatts de capacité
de production installée Fessenheim
évidemment mais c'est aussi toutes les
centrales au fioul ou au charbon qu'on a
fermé et il faut sortir des énergies
carbonées il y a pas de discussion
là-dessus mais on les a fermé sans
aucune compensation sans aucun nouveau
moyen de production donc si on est dans
la situation aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'on s'est coupé de toutes nos marges
de sécurité et aujourd'hui on est dans
cette situation qui est dénoncé par la
SN et que je dénonce depuis longtemps où
on est en train d'arbitrer entre sûreté
dans la production et sécurité
d'approvisionnement et ça c'est très
danger audition Luc Raymond prochain
patron d'aide dit aussi que tout le
monde devrait participer devra
participer au redressement de
l'entreprise donc ça ça veut dire qu'on
va payer l'électricité plus cher
les prix du marché aujourd'hui
démontrent enfin il y a pas que le prix
du marché il y a le système dans son
ensemble qui qui démontre une hausse je
pense qu'en France ça peut être tout à
fait mesuré on a un des prix
d'électricité structurellement les plus
compétitifs d'Europe il faut absolument
qu'on reste dans cette logique là à
condition à condition de rappeler à nos
notamment à nos voisins allemands que la
souveraineté énergétique c'est de
l'ordre de l'État et c'est nous qui
décidons ça n'est pas eux qui nous
imposent leurs règles alors votre
commission d'enquête souhaite
auditionner notamment à deux anciens
présidents de la République Nicolas
Sarkozy et François Hollande vous allez
pointer leur responsabilité politique
dans cette situation du nucléaire
d'abord on fera un travail de fond en
auditionnant les entreprises en
auditionnant les institutions
indépendantes je pense à l'ADEME qui a
une grande responsabilité en ayant fait
pénétrer au cœur de l'État une idéologie
anti-nucléaire et en scientifique 6 ans
si je peux m'exprimer ainsi une forme
d'idéologie en essayant de lui donner un
discours technique il faudra d'abord
qu'on fasse tout ce travail d'audition
des cabinets ministériels aussi de
certains hauts fonctionnaires qui de
cabinet de conseils à cabinet
ministériel à fonction publique et
pourquoi deux anciens et ensuite lorsque
nous aurons fait ce travail nous irons
nous inviterons Nicolas Sarkozy et
François Hollande a s'exprimer devant
notre commission parce que ces décisions
énergétiques elles sont tellement
indispensables et essentiel pour l'État
que forcément elles sont prises au plus
haut niveau de et si François Hollande
vient de votre commission vous
l'interrogerez sur la fermeture de
Fessenheim qui est dans votre
circonscription du Haut-Rhin pour vous
c'était fatale de François Hollande
fermée
la fermeture de Fessenheim est un
symbole est un symbole pour François
Hollande est un symbole pour les
anti-nucléaires est un symbole pour les
écologistes mais qui cachent une forêt
de décision bien plus structurelle et
qui toutes les unes après les autres
sont tout aussi déstabilisantes pour la
filière nucléaire donc je suis le député
de Fessenheim je porterai une ambition
énergétique pour la France avec
évidemment cette cicatrice de la
fermeture de cet outil de production qui
était en parfaite état de fonctionnement
jusqu'à il y a deux ans et la crise
actuelle donne raison à Nicolas Sarkozy
c'est ça aussi que vous essayez de
montrer dans votre commission la crise
actuelle elle donne elle donne raison à
ceux qui depuis toujours on prenait une
voix française dans la production
d'électricité Nicolas Sarkozy en faisait
partie allez on va regarder l'agenda de
la semaine prochaine au Parlement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'Assemblée nationale coup d'envoi de
la discussion du projet de loi Love Me
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur ce sera le 2
novembre avec
l'audition de Gérald Darmanin et au
Sénat ce mercredi ce sera le début de
l'examen du projet de loi qui vise à
accélérer le développement des énergies
renouvelables et puis jeudi suite du
marathon budgétaire puisque la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat va présenter son rapport sur le
budget de la Sécurité Sociale et les
modifications qu'elle propose Rafael
schildenberger on va continuer
rapidement à parler d'énergie mais cette
fois-ci d'énergie renouvelable avec le
projet de loi qui arrive au Sénat et qui
doit accélérer l'implantation des
projets notamment d'éoliennes sur notre
territoire en faisant sauter certaines
barrières ça peut être un projet que la
droite va voter écoutez pour l'instant
il y a beaucoup de flou il y a une
tentative de brouillage qui est mis en
place par le gouvernement notamment sur
l'éolien on sait pas trop si c'est
seulement l'éolien en mer ou si ça peut
aussi concerner l'éolien terrestre quand
on interroge la ministre elle est très
peu clair là-dessus de toute façon d'un
point de vue structurel ça n'est pas
l'ajout de quelques capacités de
production intermittente qui permettra
de sortir la France la situation dans
laquelle on est donc il y a pas
d'impératif absolu est-ce que ce texte
sorte vite s'il est flou il y a pas de
possibilité de trouver un agréable c'est
un sujet de friction les sénateurs de
droite vont proposer un droit de veto du
maire sur des projets pour empêcher des
projets d'éoliennes dans leur commune
vous vous trouvez que c'est une bonne
idée je crois que je crois que c'est
important c'est des projets s'ils sont
pas construits localement avec un
consensus local ils ne peuvent pas
fonctionner ça n'apporte pas grand chose
à la souveraineté énergétique nationale
donc si en plus ça crée du dissensis
localement c'est vraiment
contre-productif merci et c'est la fin
de cette émission merci beaucoup Raphaël
Silene berger d'y avoir participé merci
à tous de l'avoir suivi et on se
retrouve très bientôt ciao ciao
[Musique]